I understand back in 2004 I believe you
were interviewed for the LA Times with
is it Mary McNamara and she says
something about having that talk that a
lot of people in the industry have that
talk behind closed doors allows
significant other the conversation the
conversation thank you which basically
means the conversation about when you
stop when you give it up when you move
on when do you take a different job to
cover you know whatever that whatever
that one means to different people but
it usually is an exit it's usually okay
I did what I could do and now I have to
move on and we were in a little bit of
an unusual situation that i had my
children really late and i had one
daughter and then immediately had two
more we had three children in 18 months
so i had learned how to do the industry
for myself and then I learned how to do
it for Mary and me the two of us
together and I thought I was getting a
handle on marryin me and Ella but when
Annie and Molly got here it really it
was a very very different
responsibilities I mean I had to I got
pushed into adulthood and they needed
what they needed and it was my job to
make sure that they had that you know in
the most fundamental of ways and it was
it happened at the same time that the
dynamic of the industry was changing
pretty dramatically in terms of pay they
were reducing all of us to scale plus 10
you know in the old days there was a
pretty healthy quote system and you were
paid commiserate to your experience into
your into the last contribution that you
made to a film so you expected with
seniority or with experience or with
hopefully talent to for your salary to
increase as it would in any world but
the corporation's decided you know what
Michael O'Neill didn't take that job as
a guy right behind him so offering this
and if he doesn't want it to them to
move
on we as a young man you can do scale
plus 10 you can you know but you can't
when you have a mortgage and three
children and a wife and responsibilities
it's you have to work all the time and
so we had to have the conversation and
that's what Mary McNamara that LA Times
writer I thought I was meeting her for
you know some like career thing and we
were sitting over coffee and she says do
you ever have a conversation and I want
to oh my gosh oh please it's that where
we're going with this you know and she
said yeah I said okay here we go and it
was I honestly I thought that was the
end of my career I thought when I got
honest about what the dynamics were and
why we were getting what I felt was
pushed out of the industry economically
it would be it that would be we'd be
done and Mary and I talked my wife Mary
and I talked about that and and to her
credit she said then we'll be done then
we'll do what we have to do and she
really had my back so I I think I told
the truth I tried to and it turned out
to be a remarkable turning point in my
career in that it was quite the opposite
of what I thought I was not invited to
leave the industry I was invited to get
back inside I mean people called and
offered me jobs you know it just and
also you know there's there's the
element of publicity in our industry if
they're 50 guys in my group all of a
sudden I'm one of the top five or six
guys in my group I got moved up to the
top 10% because here I am in the los
angeles times you know in the sunday
section calendar section on the thursday
so there were a lot of aspects to it at
least i think that's you know my
interpretation of it but III give
tremendous credit to Mary McNamara that
that was a compelling
she could have hurt me with that I mean
it could have come out like a guy who's
like damn bitter and I wasn't bitter
about it I just said this is what it is
this is what it looks like and that's
what she wrote and I got to tell you I
was the feedback that I got both from
our peers and colleagues was
extraordinary for a long long time I
couldn't walk on a studio lot and
somebody said it wouldn't say I
appreciate I appreciate you telling what
it was but I got calls for guys that I
had been a circle rep with in New York
that had gotten out of the business they
were in Ohio or North Carolina or
Florida and to a person they all said
Michael thank you i thought it was me i
thought i didn't have what it took any
longer they didn't realize that the
bottleneck had narrowed financially so
they simply couldn't make a living any
longer but they thought it was a failing
of there's not a dynamic in the industry
that shifted which was which is gav me
great solace about the whole thing if
anything did but not just that I you
know ironworkers said people who worked
on placard floors I had people contact
me from you know businesses that have
been bought up by bigger businesses and
all of a sudden they were squeezed out
and it was that there was you know there
was a thing happening in our you know in
the dynamic of the gross national
economy or whatever you want to call it
but the middle got squeezed pretty hard
you